أخذوا كل ما في وسعهم وانطلقوا
بالعديد منهم سيرًا على الأقدام دون
وجهة محددة بعد ستة أيام متتالية من
القصف المتواصل. استيقظ الفلسطينيون في
شمال غزة على منشورات من
الجيش الإسرائيلي تأمرهم بالانتقال
إلى جنوب القطاع المكتظ بالسكان في
الموعد النهائي المحدد لهم.  وقد استغرق وصولهم إلى الأمم المتحدة
ساعة ولكن لا يوجد مكان يمكن أن يذهبوا إليه، ولم تكن
الجهود المبذولة لفتح ممر إنساني
عبر مصر مثمرة حتى الآن
والملاجئ مكتظة بالكامل.
ووصف رئيس وكالة اللاجئين الفلسطينية التابعة للأمم المتحدة الأمر بأنه
مروع وقال إن "
المنطقة كانت  سرعان ما تحولت
شوارع العديد من
الأحياء إلى جحيم، وأصبحت بالفعل مدن أشباح
تم تفريغها من خلال الضربات العنيفة. أولئك
الذين بقوا وحيدين مع حزنهم
في العديد من المدن حول العالم اليوم
كانت هناك احتجاجات لدعم غزة
ولكن قرع طبول الغزو
يتزايد بصوت أعلى من أي وقت مضى.
هنا والثمن الذي يدفعه المدنيون في غزة
مقابل هجمات حماس الدموية
مرتفع بالفعل في مستشفى الشفاء،
أمس، اصطف بعض أصغر الضحايا في
الممرات على نقالة على أرضية
المستشفى، فتاة صغيرة تلبس سروالها
خوفًا من أنك جيد  فتاة تسبح الله،
أنت هنا الرجل يقول لها لا تبكي يا
[موسيقى]
عزيزتي الجميع ماتوا، تقول لم يتبق
سوى عدد قليل في سرير آخر،
صبي صغير يرقد مصابًا بجروح بالغة
يطمئن
والده لا تخاف.  لا تخاف يا
أبي، يقول إنني بخير ولكن دون أي
وعد باللجوء الآمن، الخوف من اللجوء هو
رد الفعل المعقول الوحيد كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن
بن للمشاهدين الذين يعرفونك، فهم
يعرفون مدى تغطية تقاريرك على نطاق واسع
في جميع أنحاء غزة لسنوات،
تقييمك أفضل بكثير مما كان عليه تقريبًا
أي شخص آخر هو أنه من الممكن أن يغادر
مليون شخص على الفور
الشمال ويتجهون إلى الجنوب، وتقول الأمم المتحدة إن الأمر
لا يخلو من
عواقب كارثية، لا، ليس من
الممكن القيام بذلك في فترة
زمنية معقولة، في الواقع الأمم المتحدة هي الكلمة التي
استخدموها  مستحيل أنت تتحدث عن
1.1 مليون شخص أه يذهبون من
الجزء الشمالي المنطقة المحيطة بمدينة غزة
وهي كبيرة جدًا أه إلى الجنوب هناك
قصف نشط على غزة مستمر هناك
الوقود
نفذ أساسًا لا توجد طريقة للتحرك  هؤلاء
الناس من الجنوب من الشمال إلى
الجنوب وبعد ذلك عندما يذهبون إلى
الجنوب أين يقيمون بالفعل، فقد تم تهجير أكثر
من
420,000 شخص في غزة،
أي 20% من السكان، وقد
ذهب الكثير منهم إلى مدينة غزة من
المخطط التفصيلي  مناطق مثل حانون وبي
ليا في الطرف الشمالي من
قطاع غزة بالقرب من المعبر الرئيسي
إلى إسرائيل، وهو معبر القاحل، وهو
المكان الذي يدور فيه الكثير من القتال،
وبالتالي فإن الأمر أصبح
شبه
مستحيل من الناحية اللوجستية الآن  لا
يقدم الإسرائيليون جدولًا زمنيًا للوقت الذي يجب أن
يحدث فيه هذا ولكن أه في ظل هذه الظروف،
تكون المهمة مستحيلة تقريبًا،
نعم أعني أننا سمعنا من العقيد في جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي في
الساعة الماضية يقول على الفور
اذهب فورًا أم لذا بن شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على جميع تقاريرك و
وجهة نظر في ذلك